the second great awakening was one of
the most important
social religious and cultural aspects of
the early 19th century in the united
states in fact i might even make the
argument that it's impossible to
understand the early 19th century
without understanding the second grade
awakening because as you can see here
it's kind of connected with everything
so what was the second great awakening
and why was it such a big deal the
second great awakening was a period of
religious revival
in the united states
where
church membership really soared a lot of
people
had conversion experiences meaning that
they had a moment where they came to
understand their personal relationship
with god and want to change their ways
to become a more religious individual
and give up their ways as sinners
so church membership
really soared and
lots of new people joined churches
particularly women
now you'll note that this is called the
second great awakening because there was
in fact a first great awakening which
happened in the 1730s 1740s and that was
the era of jonathan edwards and sinners
in the hands of an angry god was very
localized in new england and
specifically with calvinism or puritan
religious awakening so that was a
separate event that happened about a
hundred years before and the second
great awakening as i have drawn here
generally historians say it lasted from
about 1790 to 1850 but i would say that
the real heyday of the second great
awakening would be from about 1820 to
1840. now that's those are hazy dates
but that's kind of the hot period of the
second great awakening in this series of
videos i want to explore some of the
aspects that led to the second great
awakening particularly the market
revolution and a bunch of other social
political cultural and even religious
changes that were happening beforehand
and then also explore some of the
consequences of the second great
awakening what parts of early 19th
century american culture are really tied
up with this wave in religiosity so what
was the second great awakening like well
here's a painting of what i would call
kind of the central aspect of the second
great awakening which were camp meetings
so
unlike the first great awakening which
was definitely a new england thing the
second great awakening took place
largely more on the western part of the
united states now when we're talking
about western part we're talking about
western part circa 1820 which is going
to be western new york kentucky
around appalachia and these were places
that didn't have the kind of strong
established church religion that you
might have found in a place like
massachusetts and so preachers would set
up camp meetings they'd have a big stage
people would come in tents and they
would listen to these preachers and
these preachers would attempt to convert
the audiences to a more active
and particularly evangelical form of
christianity
and evangelical christianity comes from
this word evangelical evangelist like
the four evangelists of the bible who
were the men who wrote the gospels and
the idea of evangelical christianity was
a real strong attachment to the bible
and
an attempt to make kind of heaven on
earth
so to make the world below
the same as heaven above
so they're kind of trying to bring about
a terrestrial paradise if you will and
many of the religious movements that
come out of this are particularly
concerned with what we would call really
the apocalypse or in more contemporary
terms sort of
millennialism or millenarianism
i know this is a big word
but
more or less the idea that they want
jesus christ to return to earth and rule
for a thousand years over a perfect
earthly paradise now when you and i
think of the apocalypse we usually think
that's a bad thing but most evangelical
christians in this time period really
wanted the apocalypse to happen because
it meant that heaven would happen on
earth now these camp meetings were
really interesting you know they're
happening kind of out on the frontier so
it's kind of the coolest show in town to
go see this itinerant preacher they're
often called circuit riders
so that is a preacher
who
literally rides around on a horse
because he does not have an established
congregation of his own so he goes from
town to town setting up meetings
preaching and hopefully converting
people to evangelical christianity but
the camp meetings of the second grade
awakening were characterized by a really
emotional response from individuals you
know people who are having conversion
experiences and you can you can see it
here in this painting
you know they they would kind of go into
fits they might fall over and shake or
bark like a dog because they had been so
overcome by this religious spirit so you
can imagine how camp meetings like this
as as people heard about them would have
really affected the general populace if
you heard about a story where your
friend went off to this camp meeting and
they had this incredible conversion
experience where they realized how
important it was to give up sin and
devote one's life to christianity and
working to bring heaven on earth you
might go check it out yourself so two of
the most famous preachers of the second
great awakening were lyman beecher
who
was based out of ohio later in his life
and you might be familiar with this name
beecher because lyman beecher was the
father of harriet beecher stowe
who wrote uncle tom's cabin
and one of beecher's concerns was just
that society in general in the united
states was becoming more secular and
taking a very rational approach to
religion as opposed to an emotional
approach to religion he wanted people to
feel religion very deeply he was kind of
working toward a period of religious
revival and you know got one in the
second great awakening the other really
famous preacher from this time period
was charles grandison finney
and finney traveled around and drew just
crowds in the thousands
twenty thousand thirty thousand people
might gather to hear him preach and you
know you can notice here that i have
finney
and
beecher facing away from each other
because they didn't entirely get along
one of the reasons they didn't get along
was because finney approved of women
preaching in public
which
was definitely a no-no for the time
period
so what was unique and new about the
theology of the second great awakening
well let me give myself a little bit
more space here
well i've already mentioned some things
here
one that you know is taking place out on
the frontier
in huge ecstatic camp meetings where
people were behaving in a way that would
have been very strange in a puritan
church falling down shaking shouting
aloud and also that it was concerned
with this idea of millenarianism or
trying to create heaven on earth to
bring about the rapture to bring about
the return of jesus christ to earth for
a thousand year reign and also that it
served to inspire many converts to be
better people
to do good on earth to try to bring
about this heaven on earth now contrast
this with some of a religious
establishment in the united states
specifically the puritans
right puritans were calvinists which
meant that they
followed the doctrine of john calvin
which meant that they believed in
predestination
a predestination
is the idea that before you're born god
already knows and has decided whether or
not you are saved or one of the elect
or whether you are damned
and going to hell
so there's really nothing you can do
because either you are one of these
elect or you're one of the damned so
your personal actions make no difference
in whether or not you're going to get
into heaven well the second great
awakening really kind of rejects this
notion
you can see that in kind of two
different ways one they do think that it
matters if you do good
right
so your time on earth is not just kind
of wading through a veil of tears
waiting until you get to heaven or don't
depending on what your status is so
doing good works
trying to improve the world around you
does make a difference in your salvation
and we'll see as this goes forward how
that really animates people toward all
kinds of social reforms in this time
period the other thing this does is
really democratizes religion
right if the world isn't already
separated into the elect and the damned
then anyone has a chance of salvation
and you see that in many aspects of the
second great awakening they allow women
to preach
women become really
strong members influential members of
these communities of faith they preach
to whites
blacks free and enslaved people alike
so
all races
are eligible for salvation and you also
don't have to be a wealthy church father
to be influential in religion you know
people like lyman beecher and charles
finney they weren't born wealthy they
weren't born as the scions of say the
the mather family in massachusetts which
had been you know one of the most
important religious families in
massachusetts so the second great
awakening really attracted lots of
poorer people people on the frontier it
wasn't a religion of the elite
now you don't have to be educated at the
seminaries of harvard or yale to have a
christian conversion experience so this
is the essence of the second great
awakening and in the next video i'll
talk a little bit more about the social
forces that caused a second great
awakening and the consequences of its
proliferation in early 19th century
america